But guess what?
We're going to kick off the show today
with the a Drew's News.
(audience applauds)
It's the baked potato of news programs,
piled high with good news fixin's,
and with me at the desk is my news bud
who really knows how to dress his spud.
It's Rossy Ross Matthew.
Yes, I'm a fully loaded tater.
You are a fully loaded tater.
Is there anything better than a fully loaded baked potato?
I like to butter the potato, and like wush it all around,
and like get it all mushed up,
and then attack.
Then the sour cream, and then the cheese,
and the bacon bits, and then the chives.
So much chives.
So many chives.
Oh, my God.
Well, I'm excited about our first story, Rossy.
This is the story of all stories.
We've been talking about this since we first heard about it.
We really did.
We latched right on like a baby
to the Sex in the City reboot.
There's some fresh news out, W Magazine reports
that while Samantha won't be back, the show has announced
plans to add three new friends to the group.
They are all women of color.
And they say, well, just like in real life,
some friendships fade as new ones grow
and bloom in the garden, and they've also confirmed
that Aiden will be back.
I happen to have been a fan of Aiden.
I love when he says, "The flaw is the best part," you know.
Listen, here's the deal.
I'm excited there will be new Friends,
because we're still mourning Samantha.
I love that there's going to be diversity on the show.
Yeah.
But bottom line, I need to know what Carrie's doing,
and I need to know about Miranda and Charlotte.
That's all I want.
The rest, great, I'm happy, you know, it's like at a buffet.
Here we go with the buffets again, I love it.
You want your mains, and then you can have
side dishes as well, but I need my main dishes.
I agree.
I have a theory.
I've never expressed this theory before,
but can I talk it out with you?
I would love to hear it.
All four of the women from Sex and the City are
really just one woman, like all the parts of one person,
because we were all part of that.
I completely agree.
I think that's why there were different times in my life
I felt like a Carrie.
There were different times in my life
I felt like a Miranda, a Samantha.
I was like, "Oh my God.
I'm like becoming a Charlotte York,"
which I did not anticipate.
Who are you today, just out of curiosity?
Carrie.
Yeah, well, I'm a Miranda, because I'm all business today
with a Samantha top note, because I have a date later, okay.
(audience laughing)
TMI.
No it isn't, I love it.
You like a little of that?
What?
You know I'm taken.
All right, okay, well this story is for singles out there
who are ready for their own personal Sex in the City summer.
Get ready.
Stylist reports the latest dating trend is honesty bombing.
This is fascinating.
Honesty bombing is, it means showing up to a date,
and being 100% real and honest
about you are and what you want without any apologies.
Basically, everyone's sick of wasting time, right?
Playing games.
So they're going to get to the point.
"Nice to meet you.
Now, I want kids.
Do you have a, you know, what's your FICA score?
I want to know it all."
I think this is a terrible idea.
Really?
I do.
What's more intimidating than sit down,
"Nice to meet you, what's your future plans?
Your 10 year plan."
That's a nightmare.
I want to like, I wanna peel you like an onion.
I want to get to know you, take my time.
I don't want to scare you away.
What I am excited about with this is not like,
"Here's where I'm at, this is what I want,"
but just not faking who you are.
Well, yes.
Honesty bombing, if it can be in the form of like,
"I'm going to really let you know who I am,
maybe the not where I'm at and what I want,
but the who I am."
Bring it on.
I want to know who I'm dealing with.
I don't want the pretenses.
I think that honesty bombing, if it was more
in a personality sense could be really cool.
Yeah, uh-huh, mm-hmm.
(Drew laughing)
Okay, fair enough.
Tell me, Rossy, tell me, tell me, tell me.
I'll tell you right now, if you're going to
try to sell a car, you're going to wash the car
before you put the for sale sign in it, am I right?
Right, this is what I'm saying.
So you got to sort of be like the best version of yourself
that day, but I just don't like the idea of honesty bombing.
All at once is too much to take.
Honesty revealing.
Okay.
Is a better plan.
So you want a softer landing?
Yeah, let's just like, don't freak me out, man,
I just met you.
Right?
(all laughing)
I hear ya.
You got it?
I do, I do.
Well, in the ongoing battle to detach our eyeballs
from the glowy rectangles we're all addicted to,
Travel and Leisure reports that a company is going to
pay you $692 a month to quit Instagram!
I am in love with this story, it is so fun.
Okay, you have to use the time that you would
spend scrolling to learn a new skill instead,
and the company's called How Now.
It's a new learning platform, and you can apply
on their website.
So for three months, what they're going to do is
they're going to track your progress to see how much
you can learn in about an hour a day,
which they say is the average time an adult
in the UK spends on Instagram.
I think I just learned the difference
between the UK and America.
(Ross laughing)
Okay, Ross, could you quit Instagram,
and if you did, what skill would you want to learn?
Well, for starters, no, I don't want to, no.
You know what I like doing?
Instagram.
That is like my thing at the end of the day where I just
want, and the middle of the day, and the beginning
of the day, I just like just to scroll it,
and I understand that I should be learning new skills,
but I am exhausted, all right?
I've already learned what I want to learn.
You know what I want to learn?
What Barefoot Contessa's doing now, okay?
What Kim Kardashians doing now.
That's all that I have room for left in here,
but now I do feel lazy that I don't want
to learn a new skill.
I don't, I think that you made a really salient argument,
and you should feel good about it.
Well, I'm going to Google what salient means,
and get back to you.
(Drew laughing)
Well, we've got all the news that makes you go, "Yum,"
because it's time for Food News!
Oh, yum.
(audience applauds)
All right, this comes to us from Eater,
and by the way, if you're on Instagram and you're
not on Eater, get on it, because it's one
of my favorite accounts.
I'm going to follow it right now.
I don't follow them yet.
Oh, it will change your life.
Somebody get my phone.
I'll follow them at the commercial, I promise.
Okay, well the mad scientists at Jeni's Ice Cream,
they made an Everything Bagel ice cream.
Okay, we are big fans of everything bagel.
We have tried chips.
Yep.
Or the seasoning, it' so good.
Ice cream, I don't know.
Well, this really is, you know, what it sounds like,
cream cheese ice cream with poppy seeds, sesame seeds,
garlic, bits of onions.
This also might be like, you know, a treat for
on 4/20 if you know what I mean.
Okay, let's try it.
Okay,
I'm not going to lie to you.
At first I was like, "Yes,"
and then I was, "No,"
and now I'm like, "Yes."
(audience laughing)
It's a roller coaster.
This is delicious.
I just do not recommend eating this on a date,
because you talk about a bomb. (Ross chuckling)
I don't recommending eating this on 4/20,
or you're going to eat the entire pint.
(upbeat music)